it was a weekend of threats protests and
even arson as critics accused the White
House of taking way too long to condemn
the potential for violence far left
activists ramping up their Rage Against
the Supreme Court after the leaked draft
opinion on Roe versus Wade protesters
chanting outside the homes of Justice
Brett Kavanaugh and Chief Justice John
Roberts on Saturday another one is
planned for tonight outside the home of
Justice Samuel Alito and a pro-life
group's headquarters in Wisconsin
attacked with two Molotov cocktails
Vandal spray painting graffiti that
reads if abortions aren't safe then you
aren't either
police are investigating the incident as
arson the White House question over why
it waited to speak out against the
violence
does the president plan to condemn the
leak of these Supreme Court draft
opinion or the doxing of the justices
now that we've seen violence unfold
well I would say that we have been clear
and the president's position has long
been that we should not see protests
that takes the form of violence that
takes the form of vandalism and that
threatens anyone we have not seen
violence or vandalism against Supreme
Court Justices we have seen it at
Catholic churches that's unacceptable
the president does not support that we
have seen it at some conservative
organizations that we don't support that
speaker Nancy Pelosi adding her voice to
the fight over abortion she's praising
protesters using righteous anger to
March and mobilize over the end of row
and some in the media not concerned with
potential threats against Supreme Court
Justices
I think for a lot of people the a
conversation about civility feels
um like it misses the mark when
constitutional rights that you believe
that you had for over 50 years are about
to be overturned the justices have
Securities are saying you have no right
to stand up and freely protest
um peacefully protest outside of our
homes we have a right to privacy well
women have a right to privacy as well
and women have a right to privacy with
their bodies okay so now we have our
Jesse water our very own Jesse Watters
is back good to have you here and we I
think people have been anxious to hear
what you think about the leaked draft
and the aftermath thank you well first I
just want to thank everybody for their
support and everybody here around the
table thank you and thank you for the
bourbon
I only had a few drinks before the show
today
I know what people are going to say
Waters you went to people's homes I did
but there's a difference I went to
elucidate not to intimidate there's one
guy with a microphone shows up asks a
polite question and then leaves it's a
lot different than having a mob of angry
radical activists screaming at the top
of their lungs at night time while the
kids are home that's different and
that's what I want to make clear right
now I might have had my collar up that
was probably the most flagrant thing I
did the White House gave license to this
remember last week they didn't really
condemn it and now you see it's gone
full blown crazy outside I think Elita
had to leave his house he's in an
undisclosed location
um this is from the same crowd that
bailed out the Riders this is from Mad
Maxine Waters no relation who said to
get up into people's faces and you know
Pelosi didn't condemn this she gave
license to it so they're going to turn
the midterms into a referendum on row
and that's fine because they have
nothing else that they've accomplished
and the media is going to bang this drum
because they don't want to report on
crime or the Border or inflation they
have to do this it has to be a culture
war and so just like the rage that they
stoked over race in the summer of 2020
they're going to stoke the abortion rage
this summer it's going to be rage versus
reason because we all know it's going
back to the States states can figure it
out themselves that's fine abortion is
sacred to the left what that means is
this is a religious situation this is a
religious War to the left nothing means
more to them than this abortion
situation so if you think of Molotov
cocktail or graffiti or surrounding some
Justice's home is a big deal that's
nothing wait all the thing drops this
summer it is going to get so much worse
but we all have to remember this in this
country I know it's a very tender issue
first trimester people are pretty
forgiving about abortion they are if you
look at the polling after those first
couple weeks though they don't want to
have anything to do with abortion and
everybody needs to focus on how the
country feels and that's how it feels
one of the things that they felt Greg
was uh this is a quote from uh
Administration officials tremendous
passion and that that far therefore it
was okay and they waited until today to
actually say oh actually don't uh commit
violence well not only is it illegal in
I believe all states you're also a jerk
you know imagine if a producer at the
five decided to change the format and
didn't tell you would you go to Megan's
house
I mean when you think about it
personalize it think about how mentally
unstable you are going to somebody's
house because you're upset at them for
something either political or it's
something to do with your job you can
know Greg this is different this is
about abortion and the Supreme Court
well it's exactly the same thing you go
to somebody's house in order to
intimidate and threaten them you're a
jerk and any journalist I don't know who
that person was on CNN if she was a
journalist not sure or anybody on the
CNN how stupid they are because if you
condone this like that like saying like
you know talking about civility doesn't
work then you're opening the door for
that to visit you your home and we have
this I call it uh mutually assured
civility Mac that's kind of understood
it's implied that that's what we do in
life but once you like the left does
this a lot they open the door for Stuff
and then when the stuff happens they're
like oh my God you're a [ __ ] but you
just did it Maxine Waters told people to
get people's faces Chuck Schumer
throughout these threats about Kavanaugh
remember that and then it had and it's
like oh that's and then they go then
they blame attacks on like uh Chris Rock
on Donald Trump yeah it's like they
somehow repeat debunked lies like uh uh
This is Gonna lead to the Banning of
interracial marriage which we know is
just laughable it's easily debunked but
they are they're under the assumption
that no one's actually going to read the
the opinion and find out this is exactly
what they did with the fine people hoax
they want to drum up rile up people so
that they get into a state of a rational
fear so they hit the streets and
intimidate people and then you have to
spend a couple years and work backward
and go well this never happened this
isn't real this has not happened it's
going back to the States abortion isn't
being made illegal blah blah blah Bill
Maher was amazing did you see him when
he was talking about he was like he was
basically learning in real time
literally about abortion he's like going
most of the people who are pro-life are
women and you know most and abortion
laws are far stricter in Europe than
they are here I don't understand judge
what about the intimidation Factor at
like a Justice's house that's is that
something that one you should from the
White House you could say that's wrong
but also from the justice department you
could say we're going to arrest you you
know if only the the Attorney General uh
would act against the people who are
violating a federal code the way he
tried to act against parents of children
in schools calling them domestic
terrorists I mean we would have some
sense of equity here but there is no
equity because the left traffic's enrage
but the red the statute is 18 USC uh
section 1507 it says picketing or
parading whoever with the intent of
interfering with or obstructing or
impeding the administration of justice
and that's what they're trying to do
folks they're trying to obstruct the
administration of justice they don't
want this decision to be the final
decision and with the intent of
influencing a decision the decision with
a judge and I'm trying to cut through
this resorts to a demonstration in or
near a building or residence and they're
talking about Judges shall be fined or
imprisoned to not more than one year
where you know if if Saki and Joe Biden
were so anti you know this kind of
behavior why didn't they call out the
Department of Justice so the FBI and say
even with the molotov cocktail going off
uh in uh where was it in Wisconsin
saying you know we're going to send the
federal agents out but I got to tell you
something I am a a Catholic okay and
there was something that and I'm pretty
tough uh but there was some of the
language that they used that was so
incredibly offensive to be and I respect
the first amendment in free speech let
me be clear on this but when they say
keep praying because we will be burning
your Eucharist
stuff your rosary and keep praying we're
going to remain outraged after this
weekend and then they're singing thank
God for abortions you know and
everything they do is hypocritical
because on the one hand they're saying
that this decision is a threat to
democracy they're so stupid they don't
understand that the Supreme Court has
said we're going to send it back to the
state so it can be a an issue of
democracy so that you can vote depending
upon what you believe the Supreme Court
didn't say it was unconstitutional they
said let the people decide and finally I
think the outrage is even worse when
they say you know they show the hangers
and all that you know and that this is
how people die this is how people die
well you know I don't want to get into
you know when does Life Begin and all
that although you did reference it Jesse
and I think most people would agree with
the you know the the first second and
third trimester the way you analyze it
but you want to know you want to use a
hanger how about you take a picture of
an abortion of a fetus being pulled
apart let's not go there let's try to
have an intelligent discussion and when
when Clarence Thomas says we won't be
bullied their responses bully them more
they've teed themselves up the anger the
intent is there use the law use the
statute so
it's all good too uh Harold happy
birthday thank you note here two things
one um violence has no place in politics
we have seen anti-abortion activists
we've seen those who are opposed to
certain things being taught in schools
we now see this nonsense and it's no
longer nonsense when you can't wake up
outside your home as a judge or Justice
because people are outside threatening
you uh this one-upmanship we have in
politics today has to stop the White
House and others should call call this
out just as Republicans should call out
violence when it happens or when when
the language is heated on the other side
Jesse I happen to think your analysis
right and welcome back I think that you
know we have Casey on top of of Roe and
I think I hope the conversation can
return to the facts into the law here
and whatever the Court decides to do I
hope they don't overturn Roe I frankly
hope they don't give it back to the
States because I don't want a patchwork
but judge if they do I'm an American I
can live with what the court says and
there's politics behind everything and
that judges and justices are chosen by
politicians or by presidents and
Democrats if they want to change this
they're going to have to do this at the
at The Ballot Box but first and foremost
Stop the Violence stop the protesting
outside of justices and judges homes
much like I wanted people to stop
threatening school board members with
violence it has no place in American
politics this is archaic it's brutal and
people who do it should be arrested hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else